miguel espinoza es profesor de
matemáticas en un colegio de santiago
después de décadas en la enseñanza nota
que la violencia está aumentando entre
los adolescentes y quiere darle más
agresivo se siente con derecho digamos a
discrepar y no hubo una forma de arte
arrogante y evasión haciendo que ese
violento este problema preocupa a nivel
institucional la superintendencia de
educación de chile reportó un aumento
del 62 por ciento en los incidentes
violentos respecto a 2018 y 2019
no aparecen otros en otras experiencias
tan prácticas y tan dramáticas como las
que hemos vivido acá pareciera que es un
fenómeno que estamos
principalmente viviendo en nuestro país
chile vivió uno de los cierres escolares
más largos del mundo por la pandemia 77
semanas con la reapertura algunas
escuelas han sido tomadas a la fuerza
por estudiantes otras han cerrado por el
aumento de la violencia dos años de
cierre han aumentado las dificultades en
la socialización
los jóvenes vivieron la pandemia una
etapa que es crucial de su desarrollo
que es la búsqueda de autonomía la
búsqueda de su identidad y en esta etapa
se esperaba que estuvieran socializando
de manera presencial y no pudo ocurrir
pero más allá de la pandemia las
desigualdades sociales en 2019 chile
vivió las mayores protestas de su
historia las iniciaron unos adolescentes
ante la subida de 3 centavos al billete
del metro de santiago un líder
estudiantil gabriel boric es hoy el
presidente más joven de la historia de
chile en sus manos acabar con la
violencia juvenil para ello el gobierno
va a destinar 1,7 millones de dólares en
programas educativos